hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the new DJI Osmo 3 I've
always been such a huge fan of these
because you could have really great
shots with this but what's really
exciting about this is DJI now has this
new software called Nemo so if you're
familiar with any of the previous things
that they've released it all uses this
new DJI Nemo app so now this awesome is
three integrates really well with the
software so to show you guys a little
bit of the highlights of this and then
I'm actually on my way to Montana again
which I'm so excited about so I will
shoot a really fun little cinematic
video using this and I'll show you guys
that in a little bit but first let's
check this out much like most of their
other gimble's and things like that if
you're ever off balance or things aren't
looking the way they should double tap
that trigger and it brings everything
back into focus you can triple click to
switch from your front camera to the
back camera and then triple click again
that'll switch back to the front camera
with great as a lot of these actions are
super consistent between the awesomo 3
the awesomest pockets and everything
kind of just seamlessly works together
here is the app one of the things that I
love are these little Auto story modes
out super into these or the ausma pocket
you can choose a theme to this one so in
the story mode it'll show you this
little timeline so this first shot is
5.3 seconds so I'm gonna flip the camera
around and we're gonna record this for
5.3 seconds
ready doucouré movements
[Music]
look at that okay good hit next
hopefulness five point four or three
seconds
that was a really long few seconds this
is not my best work but it's so cool
because it automatically makes these
little Story movies for you this is one
that I wanted to share with you this is
one that I made when my dog was staying
in a hotel with me and Pittsburgh I made
this using the ausma pocket but it's
that same thing
it kind of makes these really cool fun
little stories you seen Jon Theisen Rita
Margo Madhavi coach and Sheila's
indian-made Sheree Tom made sure the man
to kayo Missouri town lit huda beauty
so this also includes active track 3.0
so let's turn on active track it's in
the settings and now we're gonna kind of
try to Tyler okay hey Rin track you okay
how do you feel about that okay so I
need to see your face so okay okay know
how to draw a little box around your
face okay it's tracking you so I guess
just yeah that's nice this is super
quality content it's still tracking you
it's still tracking you whoa yeah but I
don't think you can go and like go out
the door and then just hide okay I'll
come back oh my gosh yes it did wow wow
wow this is amazing
I will say it was a little bit skeptical
when I first got this because I'm so
used to using my road and I have little
awesome a pocket that I was like what
could this possibly do that I would need
and now that I'm using it I see all of
incredible features because one of the
things that I like is I like to just
travel with the least amount of things
as possible which usually ends up I
bring absolutely everything but a lot of
times I know if as long that my phone
I'll be able to create content so having
this little guy just readily accessible
and with me like I can create such great
shots with this and so smooth I mean
this honestly does turn your phone into
like freakin a camera oh it even has a
glamour beautify is not supported in 4k
unfortunately you couldyou time-lapses
piper lapses oh wow hyperlapse no way I
wonder okay this is exciting one of the
things that I love about the ausma
pocket is the time lapses that you can
do because you can set various points
and you can have it slowly move
throughout the time lapse this also has
that it also has a place that you can
mount a little tripod it does come with
one but I don't have it right now so
you'll have to check that out on their
website but for the time being
look at this this is just any old tripod
it's now tracking me front-facing
tracking
cool wow this is great
oh my gosh okay no I don't want to try
the gesture controls so if you go into
the settings and turn on the gesture
control you just show it your palms here
goes and it's automatically starting the
record process and it's tracking me this
is why I love DJI I freaking love the
integration of their software in the
hardware it just works so well this is
awesome oh you can do Panos this is so
close IVs loses cool because you can
pick from several different pano options
so you can do a 180 and you can do a 3x3
so it shoots three three three so to
kind of make this massive square photo
so let's try that out of my room this is
where I shoot paradis fast
that's super fast whoa look at that
that's so cool it looks like a fisheye
effect that's pretty awesome now I'm
going to fold this thing up and then I'm
gonna take it on a trip so there's these
little notches and that's what you use
to line this up and get everything
folded down nicely so this locks in
place then this just foods down just
like so my mama always told me that when
I get older like she always has trouble
holding onto things and she said one day
you're gonna know what it's like and I
think that that day it's it's here I
always drop things enough I think that
like I'm holding it and it just flies
out of my hands I doubt it I don't know
anyway let's go to Montana
[Music]
[Applause]
see what nice blocking shy
[Music]
[Applause]